and so right now in Pennsylvania we
don't have all the tools that are in
place that would incentivize people to
want to make that call
thank you Senator
um we have Eric carbonara Tom Upton of
NBC National do you have any questions
I know
um
say Chris Del Mora Telemundo
hi
um
okay I heard the last part of that but
the first part was uh
all right let's start Tuesday is
foreign
[Music]
okay
in English
or AR-15 this is John
yeah
it is
okay thank you
we have
three people from CBS network New York
they are Jim Zurich Jack northless and
Luisa Gonzalez do you have any questions
no questions
okay what's your name sir
um
okay Mr Figueroa what's your question
foreign
[Music]
demos
in China
foreign
[Music]
said to me
if we can go to the Moon why is it we
can't figure out
where the guns are coming from
that's a pretty good that's a pretty
good question thank you for that
question and I hope it is something that
everyone will be trying to address in
detail because the reality is we
absolutely should be able to do that all
right we have with us let me see we've
been through the CBS network folks Ali
and Polito of the Philadelphia choir
you just here okay with the camera got
it
yes I'm sorry your name's not here my
apologies go ahead sir
what can you say about how we got this
equipment and the other question I had
is you know
Commission
because I know you guys
but are there any examples that you
can give of some of this odd attitude
Behavior particularly because the
photography has been asked to you know
perpetrator
there's unfortunately there's very
little that we can say on this the
investigation around the source of the
guns is not complete it's not that I
know and I'm not telling you it's that
it's not complete and you know the
reality is that everything about his
record suggests that these were obtained
illegally and needless to say ghost guns
cannot be bought from a legitimate
Source
the parts are sourced and then they're
put together in the minute they're put
together uh they're almost always used
for criminal purposes or anything like
that
I'm not in a position to comment on that
I can inquire of Bob Wainwright and I
can acquire doing my Facebook tour in a
moment as for social media or reports
about bizarre behavior we're not
prepared to get into that until we're
confident that reports about the bizarre
behavior are accurate and correct but
certainly in our reasons to be concerned
that there was Behavior here that if we
had proper gun laws in the state might
have created a pathway for people to
make that report before it got to this
point I'm going to invite up ABA
pescatar and AJ Wainwright to talk about
the question of the sources of the guns
and whether or not there's three
well the source of the guns as I
mentioned earlier we're going to be I'm
going to be following up with the
detectors on that I don't have that
information to start in terms of what
else was recovered from the home I went
through a few things that I know of but
again
um this this investigation and the
search warrant was executed by the
assigned detective along with other
detectives and we're going to go through
everything that was recovered
um in addition to the few things that I
mentioned earlier that I know will
recover but to your question about the
the
uh for the coastline
um I don't know the answer
all right
um did I miss any other journals
Group USA yes sir
we think the time
appropriate with regards
um well you know I don't particularly
want to comment on that I don't know if
there's someone else here who does
senator
no Euphoria in government about crime
prevention dollars we need more
certainly is good that we've Advanced
some a bunch of cuts that are currently
been proposed are not good and I think
it is ill place to say that there is
Euphoria about what's going on certainly
there people are happy that some of the
money that has been invested has had
some positive results there's too much
shooting there's too much violence
there's much work to be done
would you be willing to correct that
statement
I'm sorry would I be willing to correct
what
State
um it's not my position to correct
statements that are made by the mayor
nor is it his position to correct mine I
can tell you though that there's a press
conference happening at three o'clock
and perhaps that's a question that could
be addressed to him all right I thank
you all for being here there are a few
of you who are not uh regular press who
had a couple of questions there was a
gentleman over here who want to ask me a
question he's a member of this
congregation I will stay late see what I
can do and I know that um
Ms Trapp who had that wonderful question
would like to say a word so for those of
you in the media you gotta go I
understand and for those of you here who
got to go I understand but I am going to
give him this trap a chance to make a
last one
thing I wanted to say was
we have technology that has gotten a man
to the Moon
I find it very difficult that nobody
speaks about where these people get the
guns they speak about oh we must stop
shooting Oh we must stop doing this but
there's got to be somebody smart enough
to figure out where these people are
getting the guns
and nobody talks about that
nobody
they just talk about we got to stop
shooting
I just feel like it's crazy
that these children need to know they
can't do this
and that's all I have to say
okay